casey meyers towing the rubber tonight
and starting this home stand against the
orioles he's making his 20th start in
his first career start against the o's
121 hits for said and this one pretty
well struck right center field there's a
lot of space in the alleys here at
comerica park and cedric is thinking
three
robbie grossman gets to it late and
mullins is on
his horse a leadoff triple for cedric
mullins
his fourth three bagger of the season
right back to
they've got mullins in a rundown
get rid of it there you go candelario
running toward home
and then tag him out at home
what a job he was going on contact
and mize took a glance got him in the
rundown
and that's the second out of the inning
it's the three two that's high caliber
dude draws a walk that's what he does
it's on base no he's very aware of the
two oh there you go
that'll get you to third it's by mancini
and getting into the third field line
madue hustling all the way to third he's
in there easily
don't have to steal when pitcher is one
in the
through seats left side and a base hit
for jonathan scope and he drives home
the game's first run
that'll help on a line to left center
field scope will dig for third
the throw from mckenna is offline tigers
have runners at the corners
thanks to miguel cabrera and his hit
number 2
937.
the 01. fly ball left
field ryan mckenna camps under it scope
will tag
here comes the throw it is offline
cabrera moves up to second
the sacrifice fly for maracas makes it
two-nothing tigers
i am just impressed with miguel cabrera
right there he notices that the ball is
going to be over the cutoff man's head
and a direct throw from the left fielder
to the catcher and as soon as he sees
the ball is going to be high
he takes off and he gets down to second
base he gets the extra 90 feet
the 2-0 grounded nice play by miguel
cabrera
accurate throw to second for one the
double play converted
oh that's a dandy right there started by
cabrera
short then turned it back to cabrera at
first base
and the tigers go three six
three to end the second he's into a good
pattern here
starts getting his rhythm there's a nice
little ground ball
and a quick out mullen squares to
mize with a bare hand beautiful play by
casey mize
there's some athleticism right there
bouncing off the mound
and getting one of the best lead off men
in all of baseball
really nice job then another nice job by
the tigers defense casey mice
can you get any more efficient than five
pitches
one one ground ball base hit into left
squeezed it in between franco and riaz
scoping to score three-nothing tigers
two more rbis in this game for eric haas
well the orioles were on the road
he's made the most of his last week or
so and he has a chance here
and he is called out i think the orioles
might want to look at this just to be
sure
on the throw from zach short the
shortstop yeah it looked like zach short
had a little bit of trouble transferring
that ball from the glove to the throwing
hand we'll take a look at it right here
there's the stretch and
he is clearly safe at first base and
it's really not even close
now the 2-2 chopped to third
easy play for candelario in the dirt but
cabrera bails him out
the 2-2 swing and a miss good pitch
there the slider up and in
and zach short strikes out
badou chases a high fastball second
strike out of the inning and the game
for alexander wills sprayed to right
field
and deep that goes hayes that ball's
gone
number 496. the countdown continues
cabrera getting oh so close to 500.
it's two and two to austin hayes popped
it up
behind second base zach short
backpedaling his way
and retiring the first hitter in the
sixth here's the one two
slowly to second nice play by willy
castro
and there are two away hitters in swing
mode
did he go he did oh yeah he did
stewart punched out to end the sixth
mize
retires the orioles one two three for
the third time tonight
the second straight inning and he boasts
his second strikeout of the night
he keeps it four nothing tigers
[Applause]
there's a base hit to the opposite field
mckenna dunks one into right center a
wide turn the helmet flying as it always
seems to be
and the throw trickles away but mckenna
will stay at first
so an opposite field hit for ryan
mckenna and it's another great game
in a week full of them a two-hit night
for ryan
and this one fisted a right by franco an
opposite field dunker and mckenna will
burst for third base
constantly in motion ryan mckenna knew
he was gonna go for third right away
and the orioles are set up neatly
leyba attacks one pop up into left field
badou coming on he makes the catch
and mckenna did not tag the ball
kicks away from the catcher huss and now
mckenna will score
and franco the runner behind him
looks like he stayed put it first but
mckenna comes home on the wayward throw
to make it 4-1
there's a chopper to short zach short
will get the lead runner
and casey mize if his night is done
he goes through seven and he gives up
just one run
deep right field has he done it again
put another one on the board it's four
nine seven now
two homer game put another
number up on the countdown clock 497
for miguel 5-1 lead for the tigers in
the seventh
candelario down the right field line
headed for the corner
haas can run he's getting the windmill
home
candelaria wants to stretch it to three
he's got it
and rbi triple from jamer candelario
this crowd is electric now the one two
from fulmer
he got him swinging and strikes out the
side
make it ten in a row at home for the
tigers
cabrera with two homers number 496 and
497
and casey mize gets another win